avevo 15 anni e finalmente ragazza che
mi piaceva tantissimo mi stava parlando
nuovamente su un muretto sulla spiaggia
ea un certo punto
graziana fatturata in testa mette la
testa di tutto fine ha fatto carte in
testa fine del rapporto del muretto non
c'è il nulla
ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di vita buttata san valentino
ormai giunto e per carità l'amore ci
piace piace a tutti quanti però insomma
il romanticismo a tutti i costi e un
pochino rotto le scatole no
ecco perché il mio video per san
valentino sarà tutto tranne che tenero
insieme agli amici di girella infatti vi
ho chiesto di farmi sapere quali sono
state le vostre figuracce l'amore e
soprattutto in che modo ne siete usciti
o come avete rigirato la situazione a
vostro favore
devo dire che vi siete sfogati ma
partiamo subito col video
per un tema così importante ho deciso di
chiedere aiuto a un ospite
internazionale una persona che non ha
mai festeggiato un san valentino in vita
sua
solo dalla nascita a mio fratello
gabriele ciao tristi il san valentino è
una festa che non va festeggiata a
prescindere di questa ri fidanzati o
meno scappate andate via
ma perché perché stai facendo questo
appello la natura con senza che mi sono
cascate facenti parti amo con i messaggi
ringrazia capirà quanto momento di
messaggi che non vedo l'ora di finire
che mi piacevano anche per un occhiata
molti scusi labbra carnose questore
collega dove ha chiesto di uscire la
sera ma non eravamo dati in un orario
preciso io mi trovavo in piazza con una
mia amica seduta sulla panchina lui
arriva con la macchina e entra nella
macchine guido anche un bacio sulla
guancia tutta quanta pronta per la
serata anche lui mi dice guarda
veramente ancora devo andarmi alta
relatore il sun piazza quello che fa
mani nulla è peggio è che ho fatto in
amore
in the arrivata due anni non cambia ma
solo per guardare una romanticissima lui
mi dice ti amo
il problema è che io avevo capito o famo
che farebbe andiamocene créteil la mia
giacca miike ai media che si fanno con
le medie ancora piangendo mezza cardona
lesmo che lavora alzando
sì proprio questo voglio sentire vi
prego non date roba così
bravissima ma lei poi tornata in nero no
forse sta tornando a mangiare con un
ragazzo e un giorno mi sono una memoria
del telefono che vince compleanno amore
mio
io nel panico perché non avevo preparato
niente nel giro di due giorni doveva
organizzare tutto
alla fine riescono a realizzare questa
temi netta cena con tanto di buon
compleanno amore turca con clienti urlo
buon compleanno era il giorno del
compleanno del mio moroso
mi ero dimenticato di togliere programma
ti tolgo il saluto nel senso non è che
l'intelligenza vuole c'è l'intelligenza
non esiste in amore le più grandi menti
sono diventati dei cretini in amore
estiva l'anno dopo ci rivediamo amici
come se la banchina che creare una terra
ciociara diretto e mazzi ha fatto dio e
anche lui lo zio
il bagno perché riteneva mi sono
meritato di essere la finta robecco e lo
vedo alla mia destra si possono essere
madre che chiede se può utilizzare il
bagno ed è 30 30 secondi dopo di che è
uscito con una faccia che manco da
chernobyl
andavo le scuole elementari era il
giorno di san valentino e finalmente
avevo l'occasione per regalare un
pensiero alla ragazza che mi piaceva non
ebbe il coraggio di portarlo con me mio
padre
credendo mi fosse dimenticato il regalo
a casa me lo portò dopo due ore a scuola
lo tiene al bidello che entrando in
classe chiesa gran voce di me tutti i
compagni nota nei regali di iniziano a
osservarmi basiti chiedendosi per chi
fosse il pensiero durante la ricreazione
di nascosto misi dentro lo zaino in
regalo con annesso messaggino alla ted
mosby qualcuno capirà non ricevetti
neanche un grazie ancora oggi la vedo
per strada e non la saluto la prima fra
in zona non si scorda mai
addio di vivono mai fatto una cosa così
no tu l'hai fatto
una volta fatto il cuore io mi ricordo
che le dato tipo davanti scuola e poi
questo è per te poi si è scappato come
un razzo tipo per 100 km trovarmi in
macchina con lui a scherzare e poi avere
un attacco di nausea scappare via dalla
macchina e vomitare la cosa più orrenda
e che lui mi ha seguito e tenuto la
fonte mentre vomitavo volevo morire
quindi chiamava seta attendo la pronta
ma è neil e pato magari ha tenuto la
fronte per non farla visitare in
macchina da presa la testa dell'epoca
nell'acqua ci troviamo sulla tovaglia e
anche lui mi passate bilmente
comparativamente la mano sul viso e vedo
che si sofferma assonnato tira fuori ma
poi l'ha preso e l'alloggio della colpa
di marisa altri disastri o sognare tutti
e finalmente il primo appuntamento sarà
sotto sequestro che andiamo programma
arriviamo al lago c'era talmente tanto
dentro che potevamo volare bianca noi
allora organizzato con una bellissima
sorpresa
erano a lanterna di cartaginese e perda
prende foto ricordo con mediamente si
era fatto ma se l'avessi con una fatto
una pianta del quartiere se me lo
ricordo ogni tappa vicenda va a comprare
un bisognava comprare qualcosa da
mangiare praticamente tornarvi
dall'appuntamento con tre chili in più
in apnea e poi l'appuntamento durata 20
minuti
ragazzi siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video ringrazio mio fratello
gabriele che è riuscito a portare la
dose di cinismo necessaria per insomma
spingervi definitivamente al suicidio ma
allo stesso tempo vi voglio far
riflettere su una cosa se tutte queste
persone sono riuscite a sopravvivere a
queste figuracce questo momento però non
è non è sicuro ma diciamo che voi
potrete sopravvivere tranquillamente
anche a questo san valentino
io vi saluto e naturalmente vi do
appuntamento al prossimo video ciao
rimaniamo un'altra